many of us have discovered the benefits
of having a furry pet at home during the
pandemic now some people in japan are
taking their desire for companionship
to a whole new and different level with
robot pets while they may look like a
cat or a dog or like a robot there's a
lot more to these companion robots than
meets the eye as our lucy craft shows us
now
the puppies at this tokyo get-together
are machines
and yet from their camera embedded
snouts to their sensor-packed paws these
high-tech hounds are nothing less than
members of the family
fussed over and carted around like
poodles or toddlers
to the beach or to be blessed at the
shinto shrine
they're artificial intelligence driven
personalities minutely shaped by the
whims and habits of their owners
it's no wonder sony's robotic dog ibo
has pawed its way into hearts and minds
relaunched in 2017 the social companion
is designed to be cute and tirelessly
affectionate building the kind of
intense emotional attachments usually
associated with kids or beloved pets
noriko yamada rushed to order a nearly
three thousand dollar robo dog when her
mother-in-law began showing signs of
dementia
mother had stopped smiling and talking
but when we switched the dog on and it
gazed up at her she just lit up her
behavior changed 180 degrees
[Music]
japanese are primed for robotic
companionship growing up with friendly
cartoon androids like daryaman
but one robot startup is proving looks
aren't everything despite having neither
head arms nor legs the kubo bots sold
more than 30 000 units by september
many to stressed out users working from
home under covet restrictions the retail
price starts at about two hundred
dollars
yukai engineering ceo shinsuke aoki said
kubo leverages the most pleasing parts
of a pet a fluffy torso and a wagging
tail no idea at first it seemed weird he
said but when you pet an animal like a
cat you usually don't bother to look at
its face
but frazzled adults aren't the only
japanese turning to machine
companionship at this kindergarten in
central japan robots have replaced the
class guinea pig or bunny teachers say
the robots not only reduce stress
they're teaching kids to be more humane
two years ago moriyama kindergarten
bought a roly-poly pair of bots named
rice cake and coco weighing as much as
an infant with a price tag of a french
bulldog the cybernetic machines are
designed to love bomb their owners or in
this case a room full of fidgety
five-year-olds
our kids think the robots are alive said
principal kyoshin kodama the bots have
encouraged the kids to take better care
of things be kinder to each other and
cooperate more
love ott is a so-called emotional robot
programmed to autonomously navigate its
surroundings and respond to its owners
over the last year sales have
skyrocketed
robots are usually hard cold and inhuman
said gruvx company spokesperson miki
ikegami but since our bots are built to
soothe we made them warm and soft
japan's oldest and most successful
social robot is an fda approved device
called pado resembling an ordinary plush
toy the artificial intelligence powered
bot customizes its response as it gets
to know each patient they conducted
randomized control treatment inventor
takanori shibata said clinical trials
have validated the device's benefits as
a non-drug therapy interaction with
parallel can improve
depression
anxiety pain and also they improve the
mood of the people
since launching in 1998 thousands of
pato robots have gone into service
worldwide relieving stress among
children in icus
treating veterans suffering from ptsd
and helping dementia patients like real
pets potto has been shown to stimulate
brain activity helping reconnect damaged
areas one day they didn't speak for more
than 10 years but when she started to
talk to paolo she recovered her speech
neuroscientist julie robiard of the
university of british columbia said much
remains unknown about how well social
robots really work what we can say from
the science right now is that robots
have a huge amount of potential
and discovering that potential is all
the more urgent now in the covet era as
robots offer the promise of social
connection without social contact
they can be an emotional support they
could be a calming presence in the home
but they can also help us in other ways
they can demonstrate rehab exercises
they can distract a child who's going
through a painful procedure or a
vaccination
creators say intelligent social robots
will never replace humans but when
companions caregivers or therapists
aren't available robots are lending a
friendly paw and are already earning
their keep
for cbs mornings lucy craft tokyo
yep i'm all for it whatever works for
you i mean yeah it wouldn't work for me
yeah me neither but if we all grew up
loving r2d2 and johnny five from short
circuit now that it's reality you don't
want to robot dog tony no
no no you want the real thing i will say
this if i ever need to have my brain
activity stimulated and i hope that's no
time soon i would like one and i i see
the value for little children too that's
true but nothing can replace just the
feel and love the unconditional love
don't let me have a dog so maybe this is
the best option for i i won't let my
wife have a dog maybe we should have
slopped